what do you want to plug you want i did
see his new show you know he's on his
new show with your friend tim bagley i
love tim bagley oh my god now we could
tell the whole another podcast on the
love for tim bagley you know i want to
tell you about because i want tim bagley
on here you know what you know what you
should ask him if you want to hear the
most amazing stories do you know what he
did before he was the actor dancer
before that
he was a
what
he was the butler at the playboy mansion
oh dear god yes tim you know you know
but i did not know that i know oh
he was the guy that they called into the
room to clean up the room after
he saw things and has names
bro bro i love timber actually i can
show you our text
romance i'll call him tell right now i'm
going to call him right both call and
see who he answers no no i'm telling you
that let's call tim watch this i'm going
to call tim wright facetime
facetime on a podcast is not great
i want to hear him really good but i
could do facetime uh let me see all you
have to do is type in t on the top and
then you can find it see i don't even
know how to do anything i'm not back
here he is
this is good quiet time
let's see
hello tim
yes howie mandel
hi howie how are you guess who i'm
sitting with here
rich thurber well he's in the he's he's
behind there he's in the in the control
booth we're this is actually i'm on my
podcast right now with my daughter
okay i'll do do do a clue and you gotta
guess who this is okay go ahead okay
teaching bank stuff
wait say it again
teaching
teaching
just bank stuff
teaching bank stuff
teaching bank stuff yes
this game is going great
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't know from that clue
you get another clue
um
um
um
how about uh
work together
twice
is somebody coaching you yes
[Laughter]
i feel like a bill collector
um
i need another clue yeah this is
halloween
halloween halloween party
halloween party tony sepulveda
halloween party guest who didn't who
came but left well that's not a hint
craig
that's all hints it's just basically
telling somebody who you are what's up
tio how you doing buddy
robinson yes yes you guys doing the show
together right
yes
so tim and and for those that don't know
tim is an amazing actor who was a
semi-regular uh
what a vouch yeah i told him that what
he has to do and this is what i want you
to come on the podcast and tell about
you're before you were an actor before
you were a dancer or after i guess
no it's before right
yes yes you were a butler
yes at the playboy mansion
and you have
amazing stories right
yes i would love to come on the podcast
and talk about it just right now tell
craig because he's got no he's working
with without using names you walked into
a room and saw what
well
um
i can tell you this there was
my very first day
i had to deliver two enemas and two
douches up to bedroom four
and i knocked on the door and a famous
man opened the door and he was very
hairy and he was wearing a towel there
were two girls in the bed
and
i went back to the pantry
and i said to the head butler do you
know who that was in bedroom four
and
i don't want to give too much away let
me just say that he was
hobbled in the movie misery
and you knew the girls too
and
exactly and and the
the the butler said to me yeah
jimmy likes his girls clean
um
yeah that was the first day so that was
kind of and i remember thinking well tim
what did you think this job would be
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
so you'll come on once and tell them
more of the stories right yeah i'd love
to come on in and you'll use names we
don't have to guess who was hobbled in
misery
i know it's really it's not it's it's
anybody can figure that out but
especially since i said i just don't
know when you're with a woman and maybe
because i'm married maybe you know uh
because we're talking about craig is in
in in between um
girlfriends girlfriends like at what
point do you say like if that's what you
like like i need you to clean both
areas i need you to have like an enema
and a douche like how do you bring that
up to somebody
well i think that if you're staying at
the playboy mansion in bedroom four
um
you know all bets are off and you can
pretty much you say whatever it is that
you're
looking for i guess but one of those
girls became famous right
oh um no i don't know who the two girls
oh i don't cause you told me stories
about people that that are famous for
the girls
oh yeah do you like craig do you like
your girls a douched and uh
um
it depends
that's a whole different thing
that's diapered
it depends pampered or whatever you want
to call it
[Music]
you